this is how the raids began Before Dawn
anti-terror police moving into search
more than a hundred properties and
apprehend dozens of suspects among them
this woman biaget malzak vinkermann she
is currently a judge in Berlin but until
two years ago she was a far-right member
of parliament who would regularly
criticize the then government of Angela
Merkel now she is suspected of plotting
to overthrow its successor
this group is set up into a kind of
council which is supposed to be a kind
of government organization which was
split up into different departments just
like the cabinet of a country several
individuals were already earmarked to
take over different Ministries
some of those arrested had access to
firearms and the authorities believe
they were prepared to kill to achieve
their aims the alternative government
this plot would have created would have
had in its ranks an apparently eminent
doctor serving judge a current member of
One of Germany's Elite military units a
former police officer and others Federal
investigators believe the group tried to
make contact with Russian officials to
see if they would help in the event of a
successful coup a Kremlin spokesman
denied any Russian involvement in Berlin
questions have been asked about how
people in high positions in public life
could become involved in such an alleged
plot
our goal was to deal differently with
enemies of the Constitution who work in
the public sector
that's why I'll present my draft law on
changing discipline reaction in the
coming days so that we can remove
enemies of the Constitution more quickly
the reisberger movement is not new in
Germany at its heart it believes in the
rejection of the modern State
they wished to return to Germany's old
borders they do not recognize the German
State German democracy and think that
Germany is not a sovereign state it goes
so far that there are parts of this
movement that want to violently
overthrow the government and the focus
for that wish is here the federal
Parliament or bundestag it was once
called the reichstag back in the time of
the Kaisers in 2020 hundreds of
far-right activists tried to storm the
building during an anti-lockdown
demonstration that failed stopping that
action involved a few hundred police
forming a cordon around it stopping this
alleged coup d'etat has involved
thousands more officers operating right
across the country Dominic Kane Al
Jazeera Berlin